ya hablamos de dos de las funciones
principales del sistema linfático
la primera es llevar el fluido que fue
exprimido o forzado a salir de los
capilares de regreso a la sangre y la
segunda es ayudar a el sistema
inmunológico pero hay una más una
tercera función de la cual hablaremos en
este vídeo veamos una parte del
intestino delgado
obviamente el intestino delgado lleva
partes de alimento que el cuerpo quiere
absorber y usar para generar energía uno
de los elementos más importantes del
alimento son estas pequeñas moléculas de
glucosa que se absorben y se usan como
fuente principal de energía para el
cuerpo de hecho vamos a dibujar esto en
dos dimensiones porque nos va a ser útil
vemos algunas células aquí del intestino
delgado son células de recubrimiento del
intestino delgado la forma en que el
cuerpo absorbe la glucosa es que es
empujada dentro de estas células que
recubren el intestino y luego es
empujada fuera de ellas una vez que se
encuentra en este espacio puede penetrar
los capilares que se encuentran cerca
así que penetra los capilares
una vez dentro se esparce por todo el
cuerpo para nutrir diversas células pero
el intestino delgado no sólo necesita
absorber glucosa de hecho otro compuesto
es la grasa por lo que los ácidos grasos
que están flotando en el intestino
delgado necesitan ser absorbidos también
y recordemos que la estructura de estas
cosas luce así tenemos este grupo de
ácidos carboxílicos pegado a una larga
cadena de carbonos y como la glucosa
estas son empujadas a las células que
recubren el intestino delgado pero una
vez que salen de estas células ya no se
ven así están empaquetadas en estos
objetos esféricos grandes que tienen un
nombre extraño kilo micrones y estos
kilo micrones son útiles para contener
muchas de estas grasas juntas pero
tienen un problema y es que estos kilo
micrones son demasiado grandes como para
entrar a los capilares no pueden hacerlo
pero no queremos tener kilo micrones
acumulándose alrededor del intestino
queremos distribuirlos por todo el
cuerpo en donde son necesarios y es aquí
donde nuestro buen amigo el sistema
linfático
en acción tenemos estos vasos linfáticos
cercanos en los cuales es mucho más
sencillo que entre en los kilómetro nes
en comparación con los capilares por lo
que los kilos micrones penetran estos
vasos y son transportados por el sistema
linfático y finalmente son depositados
en el torrente sanguíneo de manera que
puedan llegar a todo el cuerpo debido a
que este proceso es muy importante estos
vasos linfáticos en el intestino delgado
tienen un nombre especial se llaman
vasos kill y feroz y estos toman las
grasas en forma de kilo micrones así que
aquí tenemos la tercera función
importante del sistema linfático que es
transportar cosas que no estaban
originalmente en la sangre y
depositarlas en ella podemos generalizar
un poco y decir que quizá en alguna
parte más alejada del intestino delgado
hay algunas otras cosas que el cuerpo
quizá quiera poner en circulación
linfática podemos tener algunas células
en otras partes del cuerpo que están
produciendo quizás alguna proteína como
las hormonas o algunos desechos y en
algunos casos estas cosas como las
proteínas pueden
tener problemas para entrar a los
capilares quizá también estos desechos
tengan problemas para entrar a los
capilares pero queremos que entren en la
sangre por ejemplo en el caso de las
hormonas queremos que lleguen a todo el
cuerpo para que tengan el efecto deseado
en los tejidos que deben afectar y en el
caso de los desechos queremos que entren
en la sangre para que lleguen al hígado
y puedan descomponerse oa los riñones en
donde puedan ser excretados en esos
casos tenemos este sistema secundario
para hacer que estas cosas entren al
torrente sanguíneo mediante los vasos
linfáticos estas son proteínas y
desechos y la razón por la que nos
referimos a ambos al mismo tiempo que
los kilos micrones es porque son cosas
que no provienen de la sangre pero
tienen que entrar en la sangre y no
pueden hacerlo directamente de manera
que primero entran en el sistema
linfático
ahora que aprendimos sobre el tercer
propósito del sistema linfático es un
buen momento para repasar los tres
propósitos de una vez pausa en el vídeo
y traten de recordar estos tres
propósitos antes de que yo los escriba
aquí
el primer propósito del sistema
linfático vamos a dibujar otro vaso
linfático aquí es recolectar todo el
fluido que fue exprimido o expulsado de
los capilares por la alta presión que
está presente en la sangre recolecta
todo este fluido y lo regresa al
torrente sanguíneo mediante los vasos
linfáticos de manera que no haya
demasiado fluido acumulándose en los
tejidos así que este es el primer
propósito este es el fluido y quizá
tiene algunas proteínas pequeñas pero
ningún glóbulo rojo o algo por el estilo
el segundo propósito está relacionado
principalmente con las infecciones si
aquí tenemos bacterias infectando algún
tejido en el cuerpo el sistema linfático
ofrece una forma de llamar la atención
del sistema inmune sobre estas bacterias
y hace esto básicamente tomando las
bacterias y llevándolas al nódulo
linfático más cercano
este es un nódulo linfático y es aquí
donde están las células y las células t
este es el segundo propósito del sistema
linfático y el tercer propósito es el
que mencionamos en este vídeo
exportar otras cosas como kilo micrones
u otras proteínas o desechos al torrente
sanguíneo y los transporta porque estos
no pueden entrar a los capilares de
forma normal